Hey, Vsauce. Michael here...
Coming to you from the Barbican in London.
It's beautiful, it's like living inside the
Regenstein Library.
That's a concrete joke.
But, I've put together a leanback of videos
all around YouTube that I really like,
that I host as a playlist.
You can start it by clicking the link at the
top of this video's description.
It's best if you're on a computer or a laptop,
something like that.
But to make it worth your time in this video,
I'm going to share some facts I learned this
week that were quite surprising and cool.
For instance, being attractive might actually
mean that you are better, if you play American football.
When females were asked to rank the hotness
of male American football players, there was
a quite surprising correlation.
The players that the females ranked as being
hotter also tended to be the players with
the highest passing ratings.
Passing.
Not like passing in a car with a... with a
football.
But passing in a car brings up the question
of gas prices.
When gas prices go up, fewer people drive
and when fewer people are driving,
there are fewer accidents.
It's actually quite mathematical.
It has been shown that for every 10% increase
in the cost of gas,
the number of car accidents goes down by 2.3%.
Fewer accidents means fewer deaths.
And here's a fact about death.
More people have died inside the Halo games
than have ever died in real life on Earth,
throughout the entire history of humans being around.
Killing somebody in real life makes you a murderer.
But the definitions of terms like that are very specific.
For instance, if you kill four or more people
at one time, you're technically considered
by the FBI a mass murderer.
And if you kill two or more people, sometimes
three or more people, with a time gap in between
those events - a cooling down period, you
are technically a serial killer. Based on the number of unsolved murders, criminologists
estimate that in the United States, at any
given time, there are about 100 serial killers
who have yet to be caught walking amongst us.
So, keep your eyes peeled or blink if you want to.
I mean, the average person blinks 15 times a minute.
But when you watch television or YouTube videos,
you blink even less frequently - only about
7.5 times a minute.
So why blink more often than you have to?
Go ahead and click the link at the top of
the description to play the Vsauce Leanback.
It's sure to keep your eyes open, because
it's full of videos around the topic of surprise.
I'll see you over there, be sure to subscribe
to Vsauce for more videos...
And as always,
thanks for watching.